[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial duel au sommaire
aujourd'hui deux figures incontournables
de la guerre froide andrée gros mais
comme ministre soviétique des affaires
étrangères et henry kissinger secrétaire
d'état américain un respect mutuel
afficher une guerre sans merci dans les
coulisses de la diplomatie mondiale
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici une brève
présentation de nos duellistes c'est le
blitz andrée gros mais koné le 18
juillet 1909 dans le village de stars y
est gros mais qui dans la provence de
moguilev fils de paysan ils étudient
dans un lycée technique agricole avant
d'intégrer l'institut d'agriculture de
minsk membre du parti communiste depuis
1931 et les sélectionnés par le comité
central du parti pour effectuer un
doctorat en économie qui l'achève à
moscou en
1936 henry kissinger lui est né le 27
mai 1923 à fürth en bavière en allemagne
au sein d'une famille juive aisée en
1938 la famille qui suggère quitte
l'allemagne nazie pour les états unis en
43 et l'obtient la nationalité
américaine est mobilisée dans l'armée
germanophone il finit la guerre dans
l'allemagne occupée au sein du service
de contre espionnage de l'armée jusqu'en
1946 après la guerre il obtient une
bourse et entre à l'université d'harvard
d' en 47 en science politique et
littérature anglaise en 1939 la
commission du comité central du parti
communiste choisi andré gromyko pour
intégrer le commissariat au peuple pour
les affaires étrangères il est envoyé la
même année comme conseiller à
l'ambassade du rss à washington où il
est nommé ambassadeur en 1943
c'est lui qui signe en 45 la charte de
l'onu au nom de l'urss en 46 il devient
le représentant de l'urss au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu un poste qu'il
occupera jusqu'en 1948 henry kissinger
se spécialise dans les relations
internationales
après avoir obtenu son doctorat en 54 il
devient enseignant et chercheur à
harvard en parallèle il travaille comme
consultant pour plusieurs agences
gouvernementales en particulier le
conseil de sécurité nationale est le
département d'état au cours des années
60 il conseille également nelson
rockefeller gouverneur de l'état de new
york et plusieurs fois candidat à
l'investiture du parti républicain pour
les élections présidentielles gromyko de
vie un vice ministre des affaires
étrangères en 1949 et en 56 membres du
comité central du parti communiste du
rss à partir de 57 il devient ministre
des affaires étrangères poste qu'il ne
quittera plus pendant presque trente ans
lorsque richard nixon est élu président
des états unis en 68 il proposa qui
suggère de devenir son conseiller à la
sécurité nationale
en 1973 kissinger cumule cette fonction
avec celle de secrétaire d'état
l'équivalent de ministre des affaires
étrangères
entre gros mes coups et kissinger le
duel diplomatique comme ans après
l'arrivée au pouvoir de l'administration
nixon les deux diplomates s'attaque
d'abord sur le sujet épineux du
désarmement en compromis sera finalement
trouvé le traité salt 1 constitue le
premier pas vers la détente les
relations américano soviétique se
développe dans de nombreux domaines mais
la rivalité continue au moyen-orient par
exemple la diplomatie américaine
renforce la coopération avec israël et
bouleverse les positions soviétique en
egypte moscou pour sa part se rapproche
de la syrie en asie kissinger et c'est
de démarrer un rapprochement avec pékin
en profitant de la dégradation des
relations entre l'urss et la chine de
son côté gromyko se félicite d'une
victoire du nord communiste vietnam
contre le sud républicain
comment la bataille diplomatique entre
gromyko esquissé légère at-elle changé
le paysage géopolitique mondiale quels
étaient les principaux sujets de
discorde entre les deux grands de la
diplomatie de l'époque quelles étaient
leurs relations personnelles pour
répondre à toutes ces questions nous
rejoignons au jean de gliniasty
directeur de recherche à l'iris et
ancien ambassadeur de france en russie
monsieur de gliniasty bonjour bonjour
parlons d'abord d'andré gromyko quelles
caractéristiques personnelles lui ont
permis de devenir un patriarche de la
diplomatie soviétique selon vous déjà
vécu il a suivi le cursus je vais dire
des grandes personnalités de la
politique étrangère soviétiques et
russes
il a été ambassadeur aux nations unies
est un peu le le résumé de tous les
problèmes du monde il a été ambassadeur
à washington
et ensuite il a été ministre et il a
même terminé c'est une carrière
politique
il a terminé président de l'urss donc il
ya une continuité à la fois diplomatique
et politique dans dans la vie du
personnage henry kissinger lui est
souvent considéré comme un des plus
grands intellectuels du monde
contemporain est ce vrai et pourquoi
je ne le qualifierais pas
d'intellectuels disons je le
qualifierais deux
à la fois deux diplomates et deux de
penseurs de la diplomatie son domaine et
est très particulier c'est là les
relations internationales sont les
relations internationales la différence
avec eux gromyko c'est qu'effectivement
il a passé la majeure partie de sa vie
dans le secteur académique et en fait il
n'a été véritablement aux commandes de
la diplomatie américaine que pendant une
période inférieure à 10 ans à la fois
comme chef du
conseiller du président en matière
internationale et ensuite comme
secrétaire d'état c'est à dire ministres
des affaires étrangères américain
gromyko lui resté pratiquement 30 ans 28
ans à la tête des affaires étrangères
russe donc ses deux carrières
différentes
donc ce n'est qu'ils suggèrent n'est pas
un intellectuel c'est un spécialiste
académique des questions internationales
quelle est la différence entre leur
perception de la diplomatie alors qu'ils
suggèrent se trouve à la tête d'un pays
qui a au moins en paroles mais où
souvent réalité fait de
j'allais dire des valeurs la dimension
essentielle de sa politique étrangère
c'est à dire un coopération
internationale la promotion des droits
de l'homme 2 démocratie et c est donc
lui a infléchi
la politique étrangère américaine woerth
disons plus de réalisme et suggère été
très marquée par ses études de justement
académique sur par exemple le traité de
westphalie l' équilibre des puissances
et donc pour lui la politique étrangère
américaine doit être dictée par les
intérêts nationaux par la raison d'état
en quelque sorte et par le souci de
stabilité mondiales du côté de gros
micoud c'est un petit peu différent
parce que pour eux comme ico qui autant
que je puisse en juger était un m'étais
convaincu de la doctrine du marxisme
léninisme
il y avait une adéquation complète entre
l'idéologie les valeurs qui étaient
celles de du socialisme dans un seul
pays ou à peu près la russie et le
réalisme diplomatique donc kissinger
était plus jaillir dans une situation
d'opposition entre la question des
valeurs et la question de la diplomatie
et promis qu était plus dans une
situation où il y avait adéquation
totale entre son système de valeurs et
le réalisme diplomatique merci beaucoup
monsieur de gliniasty nous allons
poursuivre notre analyse tout de suite
mais nous vous retrouverons la fin de
cette émission pour plus de détails sur
ce thème merci encore henry kissinger et
andreï gromyko les noms de ses deux
diplomates sont souvent associés à la
détente entre les deux superpuissances
de l'époque de la guerre froide les
états unis et l'urss ce processus ne
signifie pas toutefois un rapprochement
mais plutôt une baisse des tensions
après des années de confrontation sur
presque tous les fronts après la seconde
guerre mondiale
deux superpuissances domine la scène
internationale les états unis et l'urss
défense diplomatie commerce technologie
sport leur rivalité s'étend sur presque
tous les domaines deux alliances
militaires se forment l'otan du côté
américain le pacte de varsovie du côté
soviétique
l'opposition entre les blocs communiste
et capitaliste fait monter la tension
sur la scène internationale plusieurs
guerres éclatent en asie et au
moyen-orient où chacune des super
puissants soutiens le régime qui lui est
proche idéologiquement en 1962 le monde
se retrouve à deux doigts de la guerre
nucléaire à cause de la crise de cuba
entre les états unis et l'urss cette
crise pose avec acuité la question du
désarmement au début des années 70
l'urss et les etats-unis disposent de
1600 et 1800 ogives nucléaires
respectivement les dépenses militaires
ps bourse sur le budget vers la fin des
années 60 washington dépenses 8% de son
pib à la défense l'urss plus de 10%
le premier pas vers la détente est
franchie en 1963 quand les deux
adversaires ainsi que le royaume uni
signe le traité d'interdiction partielle
des essais nucléaires cependant
l'intervention américaine au vietnam en
1965 ainsi que les évènements de
tchécoslovaquie en 1968 ne permettent
pas d'avancer sur la question les
négociations sur le désarmement
connaissent un nouvel élan avec
l'arrivée au pouvoir de l'administration
nixon en 1969 henry kissinger alors
conseiller à la sécurité nationale et
andreï gromyko ministre soviétique des
affaires étrangères démarre le travail
dans cette direction or la tâche s'avère
compliquée
déjà la notion même d'armes stratégiques
fait débat pour la diplomatie soviétique
celle ci prend en compte entre autres
les systèmes nucléaires américains en
europe les etats-unis eux proposent de
compter seulement les armes sur le
territoire national autre problème quel
type d'armes faut-il limiter gromyko
défend le plafonnement de tous les types
d'armes nucléaires y compris les
bombardiers lourds ou les américains ont
un avantage de poids pour washington le
désarmement doit commencer par la
limitation des missiles balistiques ou
l'urss possède un avantage huit rondes
de négociation étalé sur trois ans
aboutissent finalement à un compromis en
mai 1972 le traité salt 1 et signé à
moscou par richard nixon et léonid
brejnev son texte limite le nombre de
missiles déployés sur la terre ferme à
1409 unités pour l'urss et à mille pour
les états unis à l'initiative de
kissinger le plafond est également fixé
sur les missiles embarqués dans les
sous-marins 250 pour le rss et 710 pour
washington en échange de cette disparité
la diplomatie soviétique consent à ne
pas tenir compte des bombardiers lourds
et surtout des missiles à plusieurs
ogives un atout de taille du pentagone
cet accord n'est que le début de la
détente après l'arrivée de kissinger au
poste de secrétaire d'état le processus
s'accélère en 1974 les dirigeants
soviétiques et américains signent à
vladivostok un autre document fruit d'un
débat acharné entre kissinger est gros
mais qu il deviendra le fondement pour
les négociations ultérieures en matière
de désarmement
les deux super puissances s'accordent à
ne pas dépasser 2400 vecteurs d'armes
stratégiques chacune une concession de
taille faite par moscou les armements
nucléaires américain en europe ne sont
pas prises en compte une fois de plus en
retour washington consent à inclure dans
ses 2400 vecteur les bombardiers lourds
et acceptent de ne pas plafonner les
missiles balistiques intercontinentaux
où l'urss possède un avantage sur fond
de telles avancées en matière de
désarmement la glace commence à fondre
dans d'autres domaines fin 1975 à un
accord de navigation maritime est signée
entre le rss et les états unis les
navires commerciaux soviétiques et
américains ont désormais accès au port
des deux pays la même année le premier
accord américano soviétique relatifs à
la taxation est ratifié toujours en 1975
la première coopération spatiale
américano soviétique a lieu les
vaisseaux soyouz et apollo se
rencontrent en orbite un événement
devenu le symbole de la détente entre
les deux superpuissances
d'ailleurs celle-ci ne faisait pas
l'unanimité au sein du congrès américain
un certain nombre de législateurs trouvé
l'attitude de kissinger à l'égard de
moscou trop douce le secrétaire d'état
américain était contraint parfois de
jouer l'équilibriste entre le congrès et
le pouvoir soviétique comme par exemple
avec la mise en oeuvre de l'accord de
commerce bilatéral conclu en 1972 il
prévoyait l'octroi mutuelle de statut
privilégié en termes de droits de douane
et de fiscalisation pourtant deux
législateurs américains à jackson et
vanik propose de conditionner l'octroi à
l'urss d'un tel statut à la
libéralisation de la politique
d'émigration soviétique elle concernait
en premier lieu des juifs soviétiques
souhaitant immigrer en israël sceptique
à l'égard de cette initiative qui
suggère cherchent néanmoins trouver un
compromis avec la diplomatie soviétique
gros meco lui reste intransigeant sur la
question
en clarifiant la situation réelle nous
avons souligné qu'ont elles mêmes cette
question relevait entièrement dans la
compétence interne de notre état nous
vous avons indiqué au préalable à cet
égard que nous avons agi à giroud
exclusivement conformément à notre
législation actuelle en la matière cette
initiative contraignantes pour moscou
est tout de même adopté par le congrès
américain sous forme d'un amendement à
la loi sur le commerce en réponse le
reste et se retire de l'accord
commercial comment les deux hommes
politiques promove et il leur vision de
l'échiquier mondial comment chercher
t-il à attirer à eux les alliés de
l'adversaire quelles étaient leurs
relations personnelles la réponse après
la pause
[Musique]
malgré une détente qui se profile le
début des années 70 l'urss et les états
unis continuent à être rivaux presque
dans tous les coins du monde quel était
le rapport de force entre les
superpuissances de l'époque avant
d'aller plus loin faisons le récap sur
le plan géographique la superficie de
l'union soviétique des passes plus de
deux fois celle des états unis le nombre
d'habitants n'est d'ailleurs pas si
différents à l'époque de 153 millions
d'habitants en urss contre 216 millions
aux états unis dans le domaine
économique l'urss et les états unis
commerces principalement avec les pays
de leurs camps respectifs au milieu des
années 70 l'urss produit beaucoup plus
de produits industriels que l'ensemble
de la rfa de la grande-bretagne et de la
france elle est l'un des plus grands
producteurs mondiaux de pétrole de
charbon d'acier et de fonte les
etats-unis eux se concentrent entre
autres sur le développement du secteur
technologique invention du
microprocesseur personnel du téléphone
portable de l'irm première combinaison
de l'adn dans le domaine militaire le
rapport de forces est différent l'armée
soviétique est plus de deux fois plus
nombreuses que celles des états unis en
revanche l'armée américaine et
technologiquement mieux équipés moscou
est pourtant le leader mondial en nombre
de chars et de missiles balistiques
les états unis à leur tour s'appuie sur
l'aviation stratégique et les missiles à
plusieurs ogives la rivalité entre les
deux géants de la diplomatie a laissé sa
trace sur le paysage politique de
l'époque pourtant parfois les problèmes
laisser la place aux solutions comme ce
fut le cas avec berlin ouest à la fin
des années 60 c'est un territoire
indépendant mais de facto dirigé par la
république fédérale d'allemagne ses
visées sur berlin ouest inquiéter le rss
qui insisté sur l'autonomie de la ville
les pourparlers sur la question commence
en 1969 sous format quadripartite
washington londres et paris d'un côté et
l'urss de l'autre à ce moment qu'ils
suggèrent n'est pas encore secrétaire
d'état mais conseiller présidentiel à la
sécurité nationale cependant il prend
part aux pourparlers dans ses mémoires
il décrit ce processus dure difficultés
exceptionnelles comme une partie
d'échecs sur trois est chic et pourtant
c'est entre kissinger et gromyko que la
solution a pu être trouvée
nous nous rencontrions d'habitude en
vis-à-vis une heure avant les
négociations des délégations complète
l'objectif de ces rencontres selon un
autre accord tacite était de ne pas nous
prendre de court l'un l'autre en
présence des délégations en proposant
des solutions inattendue en 1971
l'accord quadripartite fixe le statut
indépendant de berlin ouest mais donne à
la rfa le droit de le représenter à
l'international un an après le traité
salt 1 et conclut cette série de succès
diplomatique ouvre la voie à la
convocation de la conférence sur la
sécurité et la coopération en europe
l'idée est proposée en 1966 par andré
gromyko avec l'objectif de fixer les
frontières européennes de l'après guerre
or kissinger reste longtemps sceptiques
qui préfèrent négocier entre deux
superpuissances plutôt que dans un
format multilatérale cependant tant que
la détente progresse sa position
s'assouplit la conférence est convoqué
en 1973 avec l'urss les états unis et
tous les pays européens de l'est pas
gros mais cauet kissinger interviennent
aux moments les plus difficiles et les
réserves avec excellence enfin en 1975
la conférence adoptent lac des cygnes
qui qui fixe les frontières européennes
et les sphères d'influencé soviétique
américaine pose les bases de la
coopération dans la région et introduit
le principe d' attachement aux droits de
l'homme pour tous les participants
depuis les droits de l'homme et leur
respect sont devenus la pierre angulaire
de la diplomatie tout comme le principe
de non-ingérence
or cette détente ne s'étend pas sur tous
les fronts des relations bilatérales
tout temps en jouant les pacificateurs
en europe gromyko et kissinger continue
d'avancer leurs pions ailleurs par
exemple au moyen-orient
les deux pays tentent alors de s'en
poser dans la région via le conflit
arabo-israélien les états unis du côté
d'israël l'urss auprès de l'egypte et de
la syrie malgré leurs manoeuvres le
conflit perdure kissinger décide de
briser l'impasse en écartant le rss de
la région il commence par limiter son
influence en 1970 l'egypte a mis 2 le
rsa change de président washington en
profite et supplante moscou au chevet du
caire le rss tente de compenser en se
rapprochant de la syrie mais les
américains ils font tous si des avancées
la stratégie de kissinger culmine en
1973 lorsqu'éclate la nouvelle guerre
arabo-israélienne grâce à un appui
massif en armes de washington israël
repousse la tacc moscou menacent de
lancer une intervention directe pour
aider les alliés washington mobilise
aussi ses troupes une guerre américano
soviétique se profile à l'horizon
kissinger compte sur la réticence de
gros meco qui ne risquerait pas de jeter
à l'eau les progrès de la détente est en
effet l'urss renonce à une intervention
où est la limite la limite entre la paix
et la nouvelle guerre nucléaire le
règlement du conflit commence par un
efforts conjoints américano soviétique
auprès de l'onu mais washington son
parvis de l'initiative kissinger
parraine le cessez le feu entre israël
et la syrie puis entre israël et
l'egypte et s'impose comme principal
médiateur en 1979 son effort mène à la
paix historique israélo égyptienne
tout cela sans la participation de
l'urss qui perd de plus en plus ses
positions dans la région en même temps
qu'ils suggèrent dame le pion aux
soviétiques sur la chine vers la fin des
années 60 moscou et pékin connaissent
une rupture violente washington joue sur
leurs dissensions pour affaiblir encore
plus l'urss les etats-unis se tourner
vers son rival la chine les contacts
débute en mars 71 par le sport c'est ce
qu'on nommera plus tard la diplomatie du
ping-pong puis viennent deux visites de
kissinger à pékin enfin en 1972 première
visite du président américain nixon à
pékin est première percée bilatérale
dans la déclaration de shanghai
washington rompt avec taiwan et promet
d'aider pékin a adhéré à halle nu les
relations sino américaines progressent
et en 1979 elles sont officiellement
rétabli pourtant les succès de kissinger
son tergnier aussi par quelques échecs
en 1972 il promet de mettre fin à la
guerre au vietnam des négociations sont
en cours depuis 1968 à paris mais les
progrès sont maigres
la guerre au vietnam perdure depuis 1955
qui est sentant syfy avec l'intervention
directe de washington en 1965 celle ci
s'avère être un échec appuyé par l'urss
le nord vietnam communiste s'impose en
force contre le sud vietnam républicain
et l'armée de washington côté américain
le bilan est lourd et la grande
populaire grandit de plus ce fiasco
affaibli le crédit américain à
l'international sous pression qui
s'exerce veut terminer la guerre au plus
vite et se résigne à une paix avec
honneur ou de facto à la défaite une
chance pour gromyko qu'ils vivent
sceller les succès du nord-vietnam
contre le sud depuis 1970 les deux
diplomates réactive les négociations à
paris en 73 le cessez le feu vietnam et
conclut le retrait américain commence un
triomphe pour la diplomatie soviétique
pour y voir plus clair nous rejoignons
de nouveau jean de gliniasty directeur
de recherche à l'iris et ancien
ambassadeur de france en russie monsieur
de gliniasty comment le travail de
kissinger est gros mais qu at il
influencé le rapport des forces sur
l'échiquier mondial selon vous alors
l'arrêt videmment les diagnostics
diffèrent
kissinger
dépêtrer les états unis d'un certain
nombre de crises qui grevait qui pesait
sur la politique étrangère américaine
donc ils les la débarrasser les
etats-unis de la crise du vietnam il a
calmé les crises au moyen-orient et
surtout il a effectivement normaliser
les relations
dans une certaine mesure les relations
avec eux avec la russie
quant à comico lui-même il a
normalisé enfin établi sur une base
paritaire les relations avec les états
unis a fait du couple etats unis russie
soviétique
une sorte de deux de couple l'hiver des
affaires
internationales pourquoi la détente
entre le rss et les états unis qui a
culminé en la signature de l'acte
d'helsinki finalement mais a échoué par
la suite pourquoi et bien parce que
dans la réalité les accords d'helsinki
était fondée sur une sorte de marché des
changes
le monde occidental reconnaissait la
présence
de la russie soviétique
en europe de l'est ont vite eu peu
sauvage qui pologne un peu roumanie
alors que la russie de son côté donner
un coup de chapeau c'est ce qu'on a
appelé la troisième corbeil au aux
valeurs occidentales ce que les
soviétiques appelé les libertés
formelles c'est à dire liberté
d'expression liberté politique liberté
de manifestation liberté de la presse
etc
donc tout cela faisait un échange mais
il n'est pas exclu que la russie
soviétique se soient trouvés un peu
comment dirais je trompé dans cette
affaire pourquoi parce que
effectivement la corde helsinki ma canne
une sorte de changement de ligne de
pente idéologique jusqu à helsinki le la
doctrine marxiste léniniste la
libération des peuples ne le
comme durant la dictature du prolétariat
d'un certain nombre de valeurs marxistes
avait un énorme
rayonnement mondial
qui commence certes à s'affaiblir mais
qui donnait à la russie une sorte de
prééminence idéologique à partir
d'helsinki à partir du moment où la
l'urss a reconnu la valeur et des
libertés dit formel c'est à dire des
libertés politiques occidentales en fait
elle a introduit le ver dans le fruit de
son propre système on a vu fleurir
partout en urss
les groupes d'application des accords
d'helsinki et donc la russie soviétique
il ya trouvé des éléments de
déstabilisation qui sans aucun doute a
conduit un certain durcissement
après les accords d'helsinki et qui
selon vous a remporté ce duel gros meco
ou qui suggère ou qui s'est imposé en
tant que
mastodonte de la diplomatie mondiale
selon vous
d'abord il faut bien voir que kissinger
est encore vivant alors que ça fait des
années que gromyko est mort kissinger a
produit énormément de livres de livres
de très bonne facture académique et sa
pensée
est encore très
très vivante parmi les diplomates le
réalisme qui suggéra à plus marquée en
fait le l'histoire des relations
diplomatiques que celle de drôme ico qui
est plus attaché système qui n'existe
plus c'est à dire le système de l'union
soviétique
merci beaucoup jean de gliniasty je
rappelle vous êtes directeur de
recherche à l'iris et ancien ambassadeur
de france en russie merci d'avoir été là
merci pour cet éclairage s'est bâti là
n'est pas encore terminée la semaine
prochaine une nouvelle partie vous
attend avec d'autres pions sur
l'échiquier mondial à bientôt sur rt
france
[Musique]